Hey Youtubers It’s charlie, this week I
thought it would be fun to talk about all
of the classes of magic on game of thrones.
Even if the show hasn’t really explained
them all that much we’ve seen everything
from the old gods to the seven to the red
god to the great other to the three eyed crow.
So let’s drown ourselves in the grimoire
of george rr martin.
The really cool thing about game of thrones
is that all higher beings and schools of magic
bestow some form of power no matter how obscure
they are.
A really good example of old magic clashing
with new magic is in season 2 when melisandre
and ser davos unleash the smoke baby on Renly.
It’s explained that melisandre has to pass
inside the walls of storm’s end for her
smoke baby to work right.
And boy does it!
That moment wasn’t just big because of wtf
baby, it was a subtle reminder that even though
we never see any of the gods, they exist and
the have very real power.
Melisandre’s red god can’t affect Renly
as long as they’re outside the protective
barrier of the seven gods.
What’s still unclear is whether or not any
of the god’s power is dependent on prayer.
That is to say it’s unclear as to whether
they’re astral beings/demon/angelic/elemental
or if they obey the laws of what I like to
call Neil Gaiman logic.
In his book American Gods he poses the idea
that a god’s power exist in direct relation
to the amount of prayer received.
I’ll be talking more about that book in
a future video because HBO is turning it into
a tv series like they did with A Song of Ice
and Fire.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
But now let’s talk specifically about each
of the types of magic on game of thrones starting
with the old gods.
The old gods are directly related to the three-eyed
crow so be careful for a few potential spoilers
of what might be in store for Bran.
In case you want to skip this part mute the
audio now and I’ll flash an ‘unmute’
text on the screen when I get to the next
type of magic.
Annd begin.
You can think of the old gods as being like
the gods of nature and the physical earth.
Their most obvious physical expression on
the show are the heart trees that exist in
all the castles of westeros as well as beyond
the wall.
You can tell it’s a heart tree because they’re
all white and they have faces.
During the opening credits the heart tree
grows in winterfell and even though winterfell
was burned by ramsay snow the heart tree still
exists there.
The trees are supposedly as old as the earth,
making them the oldest living things on the
show.
Although other gods like the great other and
the red god have active priests like melisandre
and thoros, the old gods closest equivalent
are the greenseers.
We get to meet 1 greenseer, I won’t say
when or where but he is presented to us as
THE greenseer as if he’s the only one currently
living.
The old gods grant greenseers the ability
to commune with any natural living being.
Think of it like warging into anything that’s
alive anywhere on the earth.
Remember when someone wargs into an animal
or a person they also gain access to their
memories.
It’s like accessing a hard drive.
So because the greenseers can warg into the
heart trees that have been alive since the
dawn of man in westeros the greenseers can
effectively see across time and space.
Time travel high fives!
Currently on the show the only people who
still worship the old gods are house blackwood
in the riverlands, the people of the north
like the starks and everything that lives
beyond the wall.
That’s the end of potential spoilers so
you can turn the volume back up now.
(flash text).
Next is the seven, they replaced the old gods
in westeros when the andals came from the
east and conquered what would become the seven
kingdoms.
See what they did there, they sound more superstitious
than the freemasons.
Think of the seven like christianity.
It’s the dominant religion in westeros but
it came from the east.
Like Christianity the seven are actually all
the same god.
That is to say it’s really monotheistic
but the term ‘the seven’ refers to the
seven different aspects of the one god.
They are The Father, The Mother, The Warrior,
The Maiden, The Smith, The Crone and The Stranger.
As you can guess the people of westeros gravitate
toward each aspect based on their outlook,
so you would expect someone like robert baratheon
to worship the warrior and a blacksmith to
worship the smith.
Here’s a potential spoiler for arya so mute
the audio for just a second if you don’t
want to hear it.
Mute now....
The faceless ones are the order of assassins
in bravos that arya will end up using her
valar morghulis coin to join.
They worship death, who is represented in
the pantheon of the seven as the stranger.
So arya basically worships the stranger.
You can unmute now (text)
Unlike the old gods, the seven actually have
a bible called the seven pointed star and
like christians the faith has been heavily
integrated into modern culture and law.
They also have religious orders including
the high septon, a clergy which has it’s
own army called the faith militant.
You can find them in one of the books I won’t
say which but they become a big thing in king’s
landing.
Next up is the drowned god, he’s an off-shoot
of the seven.
The andals that conquered the iron islands
converted to the local religion rather than
convert everyone to the seven.
Although they baptise new followers by drowning
them, their priests, called the drowned men,
get drowned twice then resuscitated.
Seriously they’re actually drowned and die
for a few minutes.
Just like the red god’s enemy is the great
other, the drowned god’s enemy is the storm
god.
You start to see the pattern don’t you.
A lot of these gods share a lot of similarities,
leading you to wonder if all their myths descend
from the same two gods.
Or if in reality there is only one god with
many different aspects like the idea behind
the seven.
What a mind fuck that would be.
let’s call it the Game of thrones davinci
code.
High fives to anyone that can solve it.
There’s also the Many-Faced God.
Worshiped by the faceless ones.
Technically he’s just a different interpretation
of the stranger.
But the faceless ones believe that the stranger
is the one god with many different aspects.
That’s kind of where the idea of the seven
and the idea of the god of death blend and
get a little meta.
Although the priests of the faceless ones
are really assassins I do believe that there
is a supernatural quality to the way they
change their physical appearance.
Remember the scene in season 2 where arya
says goodbye to jacken hagar and he goes all
odo from deep space nine shifting his face.
The cool thing about their order is that for
them death is actually a gift that they offer
to people as a mercy.
As opposed to revenge killing or the traditional
idea of murder.
If you can’t tell we’ve been slowly traveling
east, which leads us to the final two gods
rhollor the red god and the great other.
Those two gods exist in this very dualistic
relationship, like a constant battle for the
world that
will supposedly only end when azor ah hi this
jesus like figure rises on a stone dragon
wielding the flaming sword lightbringer.
The religious practices that george rr martin
based these two gods on are referred to as
wisdom or illumination versus destruction.
So think of rhollor as the bringer of wisdom
and the great other as the bringer of destruction.
Based on what we’ve seen the priests of
the red god have a measure of resurrection,
the ability to raise astral beings, enchanted
objects that provide physical protection and
a measure of vision using open flames.
The great other is thought of as the god of
darkness and death.
He’s also referred to as he whose name is
never spoken.
He’s starting to sound a lot like voldemort.
Wouldn’t it be hilarious if his name was
an anagram too.
Big spoilers coming up for dance with dragons
so mute the audio really quickly and i’ll
tell you when to turn it back on.
It’s really cool but Melisandre has a vision
wherein she sees what she thinks are the champions
of the great other which include a wooden
face, corpse white, a thousand red eyes and
a boy with a wolf’s head.
What she’s really seeing is Bran.
He’s on the path to becoming a greenseer.
He is all three of those things she sees.
The wooden face is the face of the weirwood
trees, the thousand red eyes are the eyes
of the weirwood.
Remember the trees eyes are red.
and Bran/direwolf/wolf’s head imagery.
It’s pretty cool right?
Let me know in the comments if you think this
means that Bran is actually going to become
the champion of the great other in winds of
winter and dream of spring.
Personally I don’t think so, like she has
said before, her visions are subject to human
interpretation.
Just because she has special powers, doesn’t
mean that she’s a genius.
I think that she’s just seeing into the
future in a time after Bran is able to use
his greenseer powers to commune with the weirwood
trees beyond the wall.
I do think that that power will play into
the battle with the white walkers eventually.
So get excited!
Let me know what you’re interpretation is
of all these religions.
Are they all separate gods, or do they all
represent different aspects of the same god?
As events on the show unfold I’ll try to
target specific gods and go into a little
more detail about their magic.
But I’ll be doing another game of thrones
video in two weeks so let me know what you
want to talk about and I’ll try and include
it.
I just hit five thousand subscribers too so
I posted a thank you video to all you guys
for subscribing and being so awesome.
you can watch it by clicking here.
and you can click here to watch my first legend
of korra season 2 preview video.
Thanks for watching.
High fives for magic!